i feel i had a better morning coffee
thought i am so lethargic today i don't
know what it is
but my morning coffee thought
is hypergamy
i think everyone's a little bit
hypergamous
everyone i think everyone in dating
wants to get the best deal that they can
get
i think men settle because they have to
because women are getting attention from
like the small percentage of men and
they're just going to keep going after
them
until the consequence
like
i just i always think of things in terms
of like consequence so i feel like
most women will chase after chad
until the consequence or
honestly i don't even think
half the guys i've seen girls chase
chase after i wouldn't even call chad
i wouldn't even call chad as as
rolo says alpha is a mindset it's a
mindset not not money
maybe looks a little bit
like i've seen girls simple for the most
average dudes i swear to god
i swear to god i have anyways
oh my god this coffee is so good today
i'm so tired
but
i feel like
everyone's hypergamous because all that
pergames is basically saying like she's
trying to get the best deal that she can
get um and yeah like what the [ __ ] if
you're gonna pick a life partner do i
want the highest quality life partner i
can get now the issue is that we've
become delusional and we're in a society
like
where
like girls are just so hyped up from
social media
that every girl thinks she's like hotter
than she actually is and deserves more
than she does not every girl actually
there's a lot more quality women than
the man of spear gives credit for a lot
of them guys like i deal with these
people in real life the the highest
quality women don't want to be on camera
like the shy girls like they're not
gonna go on a podcast so of course
you're gonna see the craziest girls on
podcasts but like on my team i can think
of like five girls that would make great
wives but
they wouldn't going on my podcast cooked
cooked like they're just not gonna do it
anyways
yeah i think hypergamy's real
i don't think it means that a girl is
going to just leave you the second
something better comes along
because i don't think most girls are
that are married at least are
you know some girls are delusional
enough to think they could get that guy
even with their like husband and kids
but
i think in all instances when you
divorce somebody like you think you can
do better
like i don't think people get divorced
thinking
oh like i'm gonna be with this i'm gonna
be alone forever
anyways these are just my thoughts
i'm kind of tired
let me know in the comments what you
guys think don't forget to subscribe
morning coffee goodbye